yeah I mean look I think I think it
depends on how you look at it I mean
what do I think new things happen not
that often I think I think everybody is
being [ __ ] with because the attention
is being staggered in so many different
directions and shifts very quickly if
you were all of our parents our moms and
dads if they were marketers a generation
ago they had it easy
we had a consistent platform of
marketing for a very long time the
Internet that's the thing being
delivered in the phone by the way that
thing screwed it up it's tough now sorry
like ah do you think I'm happy that
Twitter's losing its attention I've 1.2
million followers on it I was at the top
of the heap I was winning I'm super
pissed I'm sad I'm not happy about it
but I'm not crying about it I'm learning
and executing and Instagram and snapchat
and that's just the way it is and it's
gonna move fast and what we have in and
again because bond is here in the
context of a lot of people in room in a
corporate environment again the whole
thing is miss structured you have brand
managers these are business operators
these are people that think about profit
margin actually the formula of the
cookies
they have to think about the
relationships with the retailers and on
top of all of that they have to
understand what's going on in marketing
and they and some random creative
director from widening Kennedy get to
decide what the creative is that they're
going to spend all their money on it's
such a [ __ ] up system it makes no
common sense in a 2016 world and there's
a reason so many people struggle to sell
[ __ ] because they don't know how it's
it's not that it's ripped apart it's
like one more time to humans in the
world decide what 30 second video is
gonna drive their business and deliver
it in a platform where every one of us
are running away from consuming it at
all costs like how is that smart